6 24 on your labor day monday hey we got
a great response to that viewer email
about wide open spaces between cars at
stoplights remember viewer bridgette
wanted to know why some drivers leave
not one not two but sometimes three car
lengths between them and the car in
front of them a stoplight she wrote
what's going on well i asked for your
input and man did i get an inbox full
most of the responses are along the
lines of one car length between cars is
generally a safety precaution people
wrote they've been rear-ended before
don't want to slam into the car in front
of them but they said two or three car
lengths that's a bit much and there were
some variations on that with really good
comments and i'll be sharing those in
our next report for today just wanted to
say thanks for the emails and please
stay extra safe on the roads today
always seems to be uh some potential
problems with drinking and driving on a
holiday buckle up drive carefully please
put down that phone too and if there's
something driving you crazy the email
address is traffic eight at eight news
now dot com